[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
ya sea conmigo en el estudio luis méndez
luis es bienvenido feliz jueves
comenzamos hablando del más reciente
informe de la fao sobre el incremento en
el precio de los alimentos
raúl este reveló que los alimentos a
nivel mundial se incrementaron por
tercer mes consecutivo hasta alcanzar
máximos de hace 10 años el índice de
precios de la organización de las
naciones unidas para la agricultura y la
alimentación que rastrea el precio
internacional de los productos
alimenticios más comercializados en el
mundo promedio
132.2 puntos en el mes de octubre esto
representa una variación al alza de 39
puntos si lo comparamos con el mes de
septiembre que fue apropósito ha
revisado la baja de éste los 130 puntos
que fueron presentados anteriormente en
cuanto a la variación de algunos rubros
los cereales en su totalidad se
incrementaron un 3,2 por ciento el trigo
subió un 5% el aceite vegetal 96 por
ciento un aumento impulsado básicamente
por las cotizaciones más firmes en los
aceites de palma soya girasol
los lácteos subieron un 26 por ciento al
tiempo que las carnes se redujeron un 0
7 por ciento y marcan de esta manera su
tercer descenso a nivel mensual louis y
pasamos a eeuu porque de acuerdo con una
publicación de ese país un significativo
porcentaje de mujeres no regresaron a
sus puestos de trabajo tras esta
pandemia coli 19 así se desprende de una
publicación de la agencia de noticias ap
que cita como fuentes a la oficina de
censos de eeuu y documentos de la
consultora mckinsey en eeuu luego de
haber perdido millones de puestos de
empleo en 2020 producto de la pandemia
de acuerdo con el departamento de
trabajo en octubre la tasa de desempleo
se ubicó en 48 % siendo ésta la más baja
de este comienzo del brote en parte al
proceso de recuperación económica que se
lleve en ese país pero de acuerdo con la
agencia de noticias ap cientos de miles
de mujeres se están quedando al margen
de este proceso y prefieren mantenerse
en casa cuidando de su familia la
agencia revela que en septiembre de 2021
nosotros 25 millones de mujeres menos
trabajando que para la misma fecha del
año 2019 para los analistas una de estas
causas está relacionada con las
dificultades de las familias para
encontrar cuidados infantiles confiables
y asequible escuchemos
si tuviésemos una política de licencia
familiar remunerada que apoyara a las
familias si tuviésemos una
infraestructura sólida de cuidados
infantiles asequible donde las familias
se sintieran cómodas por la calidad que
esperan entonces podemos comenzar a
hablar de opciones
también tenemos que recordar que existe
una brecha salarial en los empleos que
aumenta si eres afrodescendiente o
latina y uruguay agua china hablamos
ahora de españa luís porque el gobierno
de ese país va a darle trabajo a
agricultores ecuatorianos y también a
hondureños es un plan piloto que
incorpora a latinoamérica en la
experiencia de reclutar trabajadores
temporales para la recolección de frutos
rojos así se desprende de un artículo
del diario del país de españa que
expresa que empresarios de esa nación
buscando mano de obra en américa latina
para compensar la escasez de
trabajadores del campo la iniciativa
comenzará con un grupo de 500
trabajadores es decir 250 ecuatorianos y
250 hondureños bajo la condición de que
éstos deben regresar a sus países una
vez culmine el período de trabajo y
seguimos en brasil porque hay una opción
para la aplicación del programa auxilio
ahora sí esta es una iniciativa de jair
bolsonaro y que pretende sustituir al
actual programa bolsa familia en este
sentido el congreso respaldó la
iniciativa para una reforma en la
constitución en primera vuelta que haría
factible la aplicación del programa con
esta enmienda se podría liberar
alrededor de 90 mil millones de reales
del techo de gasto y que permitirían la
aplicación de la iniciativa que pretende
otorgar unos 70 dólares por familia
actualmente 'bolsa familia' se extiende
a más de 14 millones de familias y
otorga poco más de 33 dólares por su
parte ya ha evolucionado desea que
auxilio brasil entrega alrededor de 70
dólares y será para 17 millones de
familias cifra el día louis tiene que
ver en este caso con los mil 88 millones
de dólares que han recolectado las
empresas tweetdeck en américa latina
entre 2020 y 2022 usted ha ido alguna
vez a escocia tengo muchas ganas de
bueno vámonos a glasgow desde una vez
por supuesto